avec sa forme allongée le croquer de
charroux est un biscuit singulier sec
dur craquant et de couleur dorée il
restitue un léger goût d'amande
pour réaliser dix mille croqué par jour
ses pâtissiers sont à pied d'oeuvre et
chaque étape est importante
pétri
dans le batteur après on met dans la
trémie la machine tutor des
boules sont essaie de les faire paraître
plus de la même longueur et
après la goutte heures c'est la machine
qui
[Musique]
sort
des morceaux de pâte
c'est aléatoire c'est plus ou moins gros
depuis 1848 la recette reste unique est
inchangé et se transmet de génération en
génération
seules les méthodes de fabrication se
sont modernisés comme cette machine
utilisée pour dorer les croquer il faut
n'était pas un saut avant voilà il y
avait peu de machines la maintenance est
sous pression
voilà comme un compresseur et puis à
l'as automatique avec son histoire et sa
recette secrète le biscuit profit d'une
notoriété régionale et ne se démode pas
il est même inscrit au patrimoine
culinaire de la région centre historique
chez n'ont qu'à
continuer un peu l'histoire
après 10 minutes au four les discussions
mise en sachet entre sept et huit cents
sachet de croquer sortent des ateliers
chaque bourg 170 grammes et après on va
souder
[Musique]
le savoir faire et le respect de la
recette traditionnelle sont les
ingrédients du succès un succès qui
tente de s'exporter bien au-delà des
frontières du berry